before you talked before about if you
wait too long between films to make
another you'll end up being too old and
you won't get around to it
yeah I don't know if I don't know if you
get too old but I think there's a
momentum to it I mean they're really
it's so hard because you want to always
have the resources
that you need to make the thing that you
really want to make but ultimately I
think as creators you just have you have
to keep creating it's painful to wait
around I I can't handle waiting around
and doing nothing and hoping that like
you know something is gonna transpire
the perfect situation is going to
transpire in the future where I can make
the next thing so
um I definitely feel like you know I
have to keep keep moving forward and
definitely as I age it gets harder and
harder to do the kinds of things
especially with Indie filmmaking where
you're working very long hours very hard
I mean as a direct we produce and direct
and so when we're producing and
directing you know we we have even if
the the day is 10 hours on set it's a
18-hour day for us just to make sure
we we get make sure all the food shows
up that everybody shows up on set
everybody knows where to go everybody uh
you know all the props are there that at
the end of the day we clean up
everything that needs to be cleaned up
and so on so you know it's a lot for uh
as you get older it's a lot to be able
to sustain really long days for a long
period of time
is it your goal to make a film every
year every couple years I mean I think
every year is a great pace for making a
feature film
um but it is hard
it's hard to keep that up so I think you
know if I were making a feature every
two years I'd feel okay about that in
the beginning of our our filmmaking we
were doing one a year uh pandemic had
slowed us down a little bit so we have a
gap you know kind of in there but um
yeah I think every two years is probably
a good Pace if you're you know if you're
dealing with writing and uh kind of
planning and actually shooting and
editing and all that I think if you have
a two-year cycle I think that's
reasonable
so if you were to stay on on track for a
film a year a feature film a year if you
we looked at your calendar every month
would be in some stage of filmmaking
correct yeah absolutely there's no
there's no there's no breaks in that
um and there's overlap as well because
you you know might be editing one film
or waiting on something in post on one
film while you're writing the next one
or you might be
um doing pre-production on something
while you're doing you know
post-production on something there's
there's definitely it's not just that uh
it's a longer cycle than one year kind
of for each film but it's really because
they there's like some overlap between
them
why do you love problem solving and how
does that relate to film
you know I I wish I knew what what uh
what kind of drove me to be interested
in problem solving but you know even as
a small kid I was uh immediately drawn
to uh computers and and you know writing
writing code I was writing uh code and
basic on a vic-20 when I was uh I don't
know very very young
um and I just always found it
fascinating I always found it really
exciting and it it brought me to go to
school for electrical engineering which
is basically pretty much all problem
solving and I think those skills uh
ended up being really really helpful
when we started doing filmmaking because
honestly filmmaking especially
especially India I keep saying
especially Indie about everything but uh
you know if you have the budgets you can
throw money at problems and and solve
them that way we typically cannot throw
money at problems
um so filmmaking for for us is really
just a list of a list of fires that need
to be put out a list of things that we
can't do the way that we originally
planned or intended and we need to find
very rare rapid Solutions and I think
that that kind of training and that kind
of thinking process has really helped me
be very Dynamic on set and be very uh it
makes it much easier to accomplish to
make sure that we get everything we need
in a day kind of in the can even if it's
not what we thought at the top of the
day you know was exactly happening
um and I've done a lot of uh assistant
directing as well for for other
filmmakers and maybe that's one of my my
skills where I have to say to them look
you know this is what you this is what
you wanted this is what you're you're
stuck on this is what you wanted now we
have an hour so we can't do that so
let's find something that works and even
if you don't like it now even if you're
saying oh this isn't what I wanted it's
not going to work let's just get it and
then you can look at it later if you
want to redo it you can redo it later
but let's let's get a solution that
works right now and um nine times out of
ten that is that's the solution that
goes in the movie and sometimes it's is
better than the original plan not maybe
always but but yeah it's important to be
able to solve problems quickly what do
you mean by the creative part of
filmmaking is just one percent yeah
there's so I mean there's so many
logistical
uh moving parts and things that you need
to deal with that
it's
the creative part is great that's the
part that we all that we all love and
kind of enjoy then you have to kind of
buckle down and actually get the people
to show up you have to cast cast the
movie you have to hire the crew you have
to figure out you know who what what is
going to happen with all the different
departments who's going to feed them how
are we going to pay for this where where
is that going to happen and then even on
Set uh I I think set is often more
mechanical than it is creative too
because you're just trying to make sure
that
everybody shows up stands in the right
spot and does their job
um
I often Describe directing the the way I
think of directing it as basically uh
driving a train I'm the engineer of a
train that's going off a cliff uh but I
have to convince all the passengers that
everything is going just fine like just
keep doing what you're supposed to be
doing everything is going just fine and
hopefully we kind of you know land where
we're supposed to land but I don't
really have control at that point it's
just sort of like you know I brought
together the pieces
now I let those pieces kind of manifest
I think you've also said don't be afraid
just make your movie yeah I think so
many so many people I know
have been waiting and waiting and
waiting to get something done they've
been for 10 years waiting to make their
their feature and I think it's a strange
it comes from a fear it comes from from
a fear that what they make isn't going
to be good or what they make isn't going
to be what they want it to be and that's
going to be true no matter no matter
what no matter how good you are at
filmmaking whether you know if you're
making a 100 million dollar movie you're
making a 1 000 movie it's not going to
be what you what you want or what you
set out to or what you originally
envisioned
but
if you don't go out and make that you're
never going to have any growth you're
never going to have the opportunity to
to kind of learn and keep moving forward
and uh I sort of view it as I I've got a
million ideas I'm not I'm not sitting
there with oh this is my one idea this
has to be the greatest film I ever make
because I have no other ideas I've got a
million ideas I can move on to the next
idea you know if this one doesn't work I
can move on to the next idea I can make
the next film and hopefully that's
better and hopefully that connects with
people in a different way and um
by doing that you know we show that
we're capable of getting a project from
start to finish and I think that alone
is really important to a lot of people
and so when you want to make a bigger
project people are interested in hiring
people who have actually shown that they
can successfully you know move something
through all the stages of progress
humility has something to do with it too
because it made people think oh well if
it's not this budget amount then I you
know I'm I'm not going to do this yeah I
have to I have to be up here and they
start too high right yeah I think a lot
of people I mean they have ideas about
what the industry is or what it means to
make a film I've heard this is there are
a lot of ideas that kick around that are
old kind of what I think of as old ideas
and so I've seen people be like don't
put your name on any movie unless it's
like you know a big theatrical release
like you don't want you don't want to be
because you want to be a first-time
director because nobody's going to hire
you if you've directed other movies and
I'm like this just is not true I mean
you know knowing lots of people who are
who have made some kind of transition
like that it's just not true it's just
not true and maybe it was true 20 years
ago or something along those lines but I
think people are still have that kind of
fear like they only have one shot this
is their their only chance and so um
I don't think it's as much you know that
they
it's not good enough for them I think
it's more just that they're afraid that
if they do this it's going to undermine
their ultimate success and from my
perspective
if you make a bad movie Nobody watches
it it's not like it's not like you you
uh you know if you're gonna get hired 10
years from now after having made a bunch
of movies those people are not going to
go watch every one of your old movies
and even if they do
they understand that they want to see
the progress they don't necessarily care
that your first movie isn't great they
care that you've shown that you've you
know you've gotten better that you've
learned that you're now at a stage where
you can do something that's at the level
that they expect
so that that's one of these sort of like
old industry terms you know don't put
your name on anything that's not sort of
major theatrical yeah I mean I've heard
things like that before where I have
friends who you know who who don't want
their name on anything or they or they
say like you know I can't have my name
as a director like I'll work on this
project I'll even direct this project
but I can't have my name on it because
it'll like look bad for me when I'm
trying to get hired for you know a
Marvel movie or something like that I
mean they have again they have these
lofty dreams of like oh I should just
jump from nothing to to that and you
know I think for a while you would see
more of the kind of filmmakers who are
who are blowing up or getting hired on
those big things had not done a lot of
projects or you wouldn't it didn't look
like they had done a lot of projects
um and maybe secretly they had but
they're you know they weren't really
publicized or their student films they
kept them kind of buried but more and
more I think you're seeing a lot of
independent filmmakers
you know built build up and make the
jump ultimately to bigger projects